you take care of your immune system in
other ways do you take probiotics are
you cautious about your diet
I'm not as cautious about my diet as I
should be I'm a junk foodaholic actually
well that seems like a terrible thing
for your health it is a terrible thing
for my health and something my wife is
working on it but that seems ridiculous
for someone who works with health yeah
yeah
sometimes man I just don't get it right
but you still need but you still need
your vaccines I'm sure you do but
vaccines aren't going to prevent cancer
no that's true right that's true there's
a lot of diseases or diabetes or
cardiovascular disease a lot of these
diseases are connected directly to diet
right there you have a Doctor Who's
whatever he's a little overweight okay
so be it but he's basically telling you
he's addicted to junk food and he
doesn't take vitamins but here he is
pushing vaccines on people